Hey, this is just a quick video showing you that you can add
lots of different types of files to ChatGPT sessions.
I'm gonna put some files in this lesson
that you can easily download.
So you've got a picture of me, we've got an example PDF,
and we've got some example data in a Microsoft Excel sheet.
And what I want to demonstrate to you
is that we can add lots of different types of files
directly into ChatGPT.
So I'm gonna go to my desktop and downloads,
and then I'm gonna add these files.
And I'm gonna say, is this person a male or female?
Then this will analyze images and the documents,
and it appears to be a male.
So I definitely do look like a male in this one,
which is great.
We can also analyze things so we can say
what is inside of the PDF.
So you can have a chat with your documents.
So whatever the document is, you can generally upload it.
Now, obviously there will be file restrictions
for different types of documents,
and some documents may be encrypted.
So you won't be able to do this with every document.
The key point I wanna get across to you
is that there's a lot of different file types
that you can just throw into ChatGPT,
and you can start to chat with that.
So this is great for when you've got information
inside of a document,
you want to question that information
and get a quick response.
So rather than you read that document,
you could then go and question that directly
and ask lots of questions.
At this time of recording,
you can add about 10 files to an individual chat,
but obviously that might change as things progress.
The other thing that I want to also point out here
is that you can add files from Google Drive.
I'm sure by the time of you watching this,
they may have added additional connectors
inside of ChatGPT.
So keep an eye on for that.
I would expect that over time,
you'll be able to pull in more and more connectors.
So pulling in things from like OneDrive, Google Drive,
you'll start to think of it as a place
where you can essentially grab knowledge
specifically into chat histories.
And the important point here is,
use this when you're looking to get quick answers
and you don't want to read a 30 page PDF
or something like that.